sí buenos días ángel había máxima
expectación en el foro económico de
davos para seguir al presidente
ucraniano voló 1012 lenski ha pedido
estas máximas sanciones sobre todo al
embargo del petróleo un mensaje muy
claro los países europeos que llevan
tres semanas tratando de negociar un
sexto paquete de sanciones las que se
incluye precisamente este embargo al
petróleo en la unión europea las
sanciones requieren unanimidad de todos
los países y ahora mismo llevan tres
semanas de bloqueo a causa del veto que
ha impuesto hungría porque es un país
que no tiene salida al mar y que depende
enteramente del gas y también del
petróleo de rusia e insiste en que
necesita una mayor ayuda de bruselas
para hacer frente a un gasto enorme para
su país aseguran desde el gobierno
húngaro es una cuestión que se dé
precisamente se va a hablar la próxima
reunión de jefes de estado de gobierno
que se reúnen de forma extraordinaria la
semana que viene de lenski también ha
reclamado que haya que se aísle al
máximo a nivel financiero y también a
nivel comercial a rusia algo que ya ha
empezado a hacer la unión europea pero
según el ente y esto no es suficiente
este discurso de céleres que como
comentábamos en uno de los puntos que
más se esperaban de el foro económico de
davos en que la guerra de ucrania está
absolutamente que está absorbente
planeando en todos los debates de este
foro económico entre ellos la crisis
alimentaria la que habéis hecho antes en
referencia a la unión europea en la que
están representadas los presidentes de
las instituciones europeas también van a
abordar esta cuestión preocupa mucho
recordemos ucrania uno de los mayores
exportadores de trigo del mundo y debido
al bloqueo de rusia por la el de los
puertos por esta guerra se está evitando
que se pueda exportar el trigo la unión
europea y ya ha empezado a dar ayudas a
ucrania para que puedan exportar a nivel
de carretera las exportaciones de trigo
a través de polonia los países bálticos
algo que no está haciendo nada fácil
sobre todo para contrarrestar esta
desinformación desde rusia que aseguran
que los puertos están bloqueados por las
sanciones europeas algo que el jefe de
la diplomacia europea se aburre y ha
insistido que no es cierto me gustaría
ser excelencia antes de hablar en davos
les dijo que espera que la unión europea
en el bloque hablemos de eso
y así es en un encuentro con el
presidente de polonia andrzej duda hace
lenski dijo que se muestra confiado en
que pronto ucrania puede ser consideró
países candidatos algo que se va a
hablar precisamente en la cumbre de
jefes de estado de gobierno de junio
aunque hay dudas de cómo se va a poder
hacer ahora mismo la comisión europea
está analizando está haciendo un informe
para poder aceptar si o no esta
candidatura de ucrania en cualquier caso
el presidente de francés de manuel
macrón ha relajado un poco la
posibilidad de que aunque sea país el
candidato o ucrania hay que ver una vez
haya pueda entrar en la unión europea
porque es un proceso muy largo que puede
tardar incluso 15 o 20 años ha asegurado
el ministro europeo francés clement von